[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
It's that time
again-- more Chrome.
Head over to the post
linked in the description
below to read about some
of the great updates
in Chrome 53 Beta including
Shadow DOM V1, the Payment
Request API, Android
autoplay, and more.
Speaking of the
Payment Request API,
it makes checkout
flows easier, faster,
and consistent on
shopping sites.
And we have a great post for you
with a video overview and code
to get you started.
Parsey McParseface is
the world's most accurate
English parser.
And now it has 40 cousins.
Parsey's Cousins is a collection
of pretrained syntactic models
for 40 languages.
Take a look at the post
for the really cool way
we built these models.
Also, the GitHub
link is there, too.
And we'll be at the 2016 Annual
Meeting of the Association
for Computational Linguistics.
If you can't make it to
Berlin for the conference,
instead check out
our post with links
to all the Google
research being presented.
Over the last six months, we've
made a number of improvements
to the AdWords community,
which is a great place
to help you improve performance,
share best practices,
and ask an expert
your questions.
Take a look.
Streak is a full-blown CRM
built directly into Gmail
and built on the
Google Cloud Platform.
Read the post to learn how they
added advanced functionality
into the Cloud Datastore
object storage system.
It's a cool post with a
lot of detail and code.
The App Engine Admin API lets
you manage your application
programmatically.
With it, you can deploy to App
Engine from your own custom
toolchain, write your own A/B
testing framework, and more.
Oh, and now it's
generally available.
Check out the post for
an example with code.
Make sure to subscribe
to this channel.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]